la sortie un micro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une question difficile parce que
si je dois parler mais roman les
personnages mes héros sont toujours des
personnages très tourmenté qui ont des
traumatismes qui ont un passé sombre
secret et
en l'occurrence je peux pas souhaité un
pays d'avoir un président qui serait un
personnage parce que je j'espère je
souhaite des présidents beaucoup plus
limpide beaucoup de terre
ado clos sans aucun doute
c'est difficile de dire le premier des
premiers mais un de ceux qui m'a le plus
marqué c'est lune sanglante de james
ellroy
[Musique]
on a toujours l'espoir de voir adapter
son dernier roman là
les promise comme on le roman qui vient
d'être publié j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils
soient d'appeler oui parce que ça se
passe à berlin en 1939 sera très heureux
de voir une très belle reconstitution
[Musique]
c'est assez proche quand même les deux
ont beaucoup beaucoup de qualités mais
je dirais george romero pour pour la
nuit des morts-vivants tu es quand même
un grand classique
il me reste une grande curiosité 1 je
pense un sens de l' enquête pour tous
mes livres aujourd'hui je mène toujours
1 des petits reportages pour me
renseigner sur tel ou tel détail c'est
quelque chose qui enrichit mes livres
[Musique]